things got emotional on this week's
Dancing with the Stars Alexa pano Vega
was eliminated and her husband Carlos
was very visibly upset PT was with the
27 year old actress after the show where
she teared up talking about her man he
is you did so great you're so great you
two were seriously so many people's
favorites and you guys have so much to
be proud of what are you gonna take away
from this as a couple
honestly this journey was so beautiful
and I do think how did this process I
feel like I just gained so much more
confidence I had an eating disorder I
struggled with bulimia for so long why
were you afraid to talk about it and
what gave you the strength to talk about
it now I never wanted people to
associate me with a problem and I feel
like that's the biggest fear you have
with trying to overcome that I don't
want anybody to associate me with
bulimia or with an eating disorder in
any way so finally being able to just
let it go and say you know what I Know
Who I am and I know I've gotten past
this and I'm proud of myself like for me
I'm just like let the world know because
whoever is going through that I wish I
had somebody to be real with me who is
just so open about it